pete davidson we all know him
you're right it is going to get worse i
told you we talked about that
we talked about max barr in um staten
island
that they've been protesting hey yo
we're starting the constitution
well staten island 75 guys screaming let
them talk over each other
a lot of people have been asking i've
been hearing this i'm sure you've been
hearing this all around it's like what
does pete davidson think about this
am hearing that no okay well neither of
us i've been blissfully ignorant of
anything
related to pete davidson well guess what
pete davidson did the weekend update and
he finally addressed
the staten island thing thank god on
wednesday residents of staten island
held a large rally outside max pub
to protest restrictions on indoor dining
with more on this is staten island
native pete davidson
does colin jost have one of those
things you've seen them you know
no the front of fake hair things oh oh
yeah the
the ones that stick on you maybe i i
really don't know
you knew his name that's more than i
knew thank you
it's gonna be hard to follow that
giuliani fart
thank you because remember giuliani
farted
hey by the way pete don't dress up uh
you know it's only
saturday night live i hate it remember
when everybody a weekend up that used to
wear a suit
his schtick is that he's a bum yeah i
know because
and it's honestly they're they're
marketing him this way and it's sad to
say
because there's a lot of bums
out there now who kind of look at pete
davidson and go that's me and it's like
that's not a good you never want to
emulate that pete davidson dresses on
snl the way adam sandler dresses on his
free time
sandler's earned it no no i said free
time but that's it
when santa
but yeah sandler's got kids and [__] now
whenever he's walking out of like a
walmart it's just
basketball shorts in a jersey but that
man has earned it
so i just want to warn you you're gonna
get angry
to follow that giuliani fart thank you
yeah i saw uh the protest
people were outside the bar shouting
about freedom
taunting the cops chanting that they
should arrest the governor but it's
staten island so i assume that it was
just like a typical last call
and are you against these protests i
mean kind of but i'm also just happy i'm
no longer the first thing people think
of
when they say what's the worst thing
about staten island
oh no no no i still think it's you
i'm sorry i want to help you out here
pete please you're above
all of the garbage dumps yes do you
understand that right now
there could be an attack on staten
island that would make
911 look like your father's never having
another birthday again
and i would still still think you're the
worst thing at staten island
period well if we had an attack on
staten island it would be like a reverse
911.
that's a good point come on that's not
true people like you
yeah but not in the right way you know
like i don't get to like host the emmys
like you and che
but i did just find out there's an etsy
store selling
pete davidson vibrators yeah but hey
pete do you know why you're never gonna
why you're not being asked to host the
emmys because colin jost and michael che
are safe and boring and they'll show up
in a tux
and they'll do what the [__] they're
told that's why they were asked to go
there and why you are not
because they will show up and go yes sir
no sir please and thank you
yeah you'll show up in a north face
jacket [__] on heroin so yeah
and start writing on instagram that
you're going to keep yourself two hours
before showtime
while they have a [__] 200 000
orchestra waiting
and warming up probably i'm sad i'm
taking
xanax that's why colin just and michael
chase show up and go
yeah we got here a half hour early uh
tell me word for word what i'm supposed
to say
tell me what yeah you got it in three
two one how weird is that you could buy
a vibrator with my face on it for
fifteen dollars or one without my face
for twenty dollars
i don't even think he's self-deprecating
right now but don't worry about it he
becomes more hateable i promise i got a
cut of the sails now i know how
chappelle feels
right you will never know how dave
chappelle feels in
any way shape or form what are you
trying to say dude he's not as good as
chappelle
he's not as good as charlie murphy he's
not as good as ashy larry
actually donald rawlings is very funny
um back to the pub what exactly were
they protesting
well the bar uh shockingly is in a
neighborhood with the second highest
coveted infections in all of new york
so the rule is that they're supposed to
let people eat or drink outside
and the owner said no one wants to do
that because no no no no no
sure it's not that nobody wants to we
saw that bar
we all saw that bar we watched that
video there's about two square feet of
space in front of them there's no place
you know outdoor eating there is nowhere
to eat out there we saw that
it's a pub most pubs in new york are
usually
a leased building very skinny not a lot
of frontage
you go in and they like you've seen like
usually when you go to a bar in new york
you have to go all it's always
long and you got to go way in the back
that's how they are set up
there is no outdoor seating there yeah
bars are set up like a hallway fight
scene
[Laughter]
you're right like jason porn movie we're
like we're getting
chased exactly it's just really long and
thin
yeah so the rule is that they're
supposed to let people eat or drink
outside
and the owner said no one wants to do
that because they'll go out of business
but the argument that people in staten
island don't want to drink outside can
be disproven by going to
literally any little league game
i hate him by the way which also you're
not allowed to have i hate him you're
not allowed to have little league games
either
in those areas yeah so funny joke about
another thing you're not allowed to do
that's hilarious hey just because you
live with your mom and never leave your
house doesn't mean other people don't
yeah like some somebody look i admitted
hey pete
i'm with you bro most of the time i
smoke pot and don't leave my house
either
but you know what i would never do i
would never let that affect my judgment
enough to say oh hey guy who has got
three kids and a mortgage
you're not allowed to take your kid to
karate class [__] you
[__] you and your job see i don't feel
like that's my place you know what i
mean you know i'll just chill in the
house smoke weed
you take your kid to karate and go to
work yeah hey you know what's funny that
bartender that
that bartender they got five thousand
dollar fine that isn't a millionaire on
snl that's
really funny for her wow that is that's
like really funny dude [__] yeah dude it
was [__] 5 000 dude
i take it that you found these protests
frustrating yeah man they're making us
look like babies
you know you know it's bad when no no
what's making you look like
babies is being afraid to go to a bar
and drink outside that's what makes you
look like a baby
or crying on twitter that you're gonna
kick off every five minutes
that makes you seem like a baby or
dating women that are literally babies
which one she spent didn't he date joe
what's her face julia roberts 19 year
old daughter and yeah that was creepy i
was just wondering about the ariana
grande thing because i would
no no what's up with our [__] at our
arnie grano grande like that's your gift
if you don't and even people in boston
are like ah drink it home you guys
[Laughter]
and then he laughs at his own [__] like
what the [__] with this guy
and do you think that people should stay
at home until the pandemic gets better
yeah everyone wants to go have fun but
there's plenty of stuff you could do at
home
like you you're not staying at home
though you're doing this show
hey fun fact you know how snl does have
a limited crowd now do you hear them
you know how they do that they have
found a loophole
in the mandates and they are paying
themselves as employees
that's this is for a look it up i'm
swear to god i looked it up they're
paying themselves as employees instead
of actors instead of performers
and because they're employees they're
allowed to have a limited crowd
indoors they can they're allowed to oh
yeah
um there was another one i just saw a
video the other day
of a woman i think it was in l.a she was
told it may not have been l.a it might
have been another city but
she was told she can't have outdoor uh
dining
and then like the next day she's she
noticed that the movie theater across
the street
which was like a big chain was given a
special license for outdoor
dining and she's like they told me no
i'm right across the street and they
were like yeah
so this is i'm telling you man these big
businesses
are getting completely [__] they're
getting carp launched to do whatever the
[__] they want
and i mean even if you live like if you
have a [__] cafe that's
right next to one they're going to be
like oh wawa wawa's open but you gotta
you better [__] wrap this up now and
you're like
oh by the way i make eggs and smoothies
too it's the same place here's how
they're doing the crowd they're paying
the audience
and the audience speaks exactly this
isn't this is not enough money in the
world
this isn't mad tv um they're paying the
audience and the
audience are employees and that's how
they found the loophole to have an
audience are they calling it hazard pay
jesus chris actually yeah uh i'm doing
this
online table read of it's a wonderful
life for charity uh it's with a bunch of
other actors i love too
and i get to play george bailey and then
we'll stream it online to raise money
yeah that's that's really uh that's
really great pete yeah you would think
yeah you should tell that to the
thousands of people on twitter who are
extremely angry about it
why are they so mad that i'm doing a
little online table
would you like to answer why he's so mad
no well first i'd like to
dude why is snl letting this happen
like like just letting pete do the pete
davidson show like he goes up and like
hey [__] go get a therapist you know
what i mean like this is the kind of
thing
you should be sitting down with a
therapist and talking about not doing it
on tv is a bit this isn't even fun
every time he goes on on weekend update
it's pete davidson pete davidson pete
davidson me me me my real life like
that's not what this show used to be
this used to be a sketch comedy show
like
bill hater would do that what was the
stefan guy or whatever that was and that
wasn't bill hader
that was bill hader doing it and it was
hilarious like you know what i mean
it's it's you know what you know what i
miss more than anything honestly
freedom i miss when they only they did
it like twice on snl when they had colin
quinn come in
drunk from the holiday oh yeah yeah yeah
he's spilling his eggnog all over the
place
that was one of my favorite favorite
times they did that
so pete davidson the reason that people
don't want you to do it's a wonderful
life is because that is one of a
classic christmas movie that people look
back on through years and it's about a
man changing his life for the better
because
what would the world be like if if he if
he wasn't around in it
and the problem with doing a what a
wonderful life with pete davidson is if
you weren't around the movie would end
with you killing yourself because the
world would be a better place
it would have the opposite message see
it's a wonderful life
and it's the same you're just going to
ruin a good movie and at the end you're
going to be like oh wow i guess it's my
family that matters i guess
not life's not all about weed and xboxes
and knuckle tattoos
oh wow i guess i'm a changed man now
and that's the other problem pete we're
going to watch you in movie after movie
after movie
where you play pete davidson and at the
end you become better
you become a better version of yourself
then the problem is next week you're on
snl pete davidson still [__] pete
davidson
so it's watching you improve 500 times
in these fictional movies
but never improve in your real life pete
that's why people hate you
they hate you because you're a perpetual
man child
and anybody who hates that sort of thing
is going to despise you
anybody who has to get up and punch a
clock
and go to a real job hates you and they
should
angry about it why are they what if he
does that what if they do it's a
wonderful life and he does it just like
[__] uh
what's his face and uh jimmy stewart and
he's like at the bridge
and he's like man i'm gonna jump off
this bridge and then the angel appears
and he's like
do it push do a flip pushes him dude
the movie's four minutes long and then
that movie just ends with
him crashing against the ice cold rocks
in the in the [__] lake and the angel
going
mission accomplished well i guess now
it's a wonderful life and he just
the movie ends with the angel the angel
calling up um
what's his face the comedian that got in
trouble for the for the
stuff oh uh uh dude we've had him on our
show i know i just can't think of his
name right now and i come now you made
me forgot
god damn it that guy no i [__] now we
gotta know dude he's been on our show he
was on our show with doug stanhope doug
santel's friend
yeah i can't remember the name i'm sure
he likes to be called like stan hope's
friend yeah i don't
someone will tell us in the chat that
i'm sure they'll tell them seth gilles
say
shane gillis seth gillis old seth gill i
was thinking of seth gilliam from the
wire
seth gilligan seth gilligan on our show
the angel calls shane gillis and goes
you got your job back did you see that
this is really good you're going to like
this
i think you're going to enjoy this a lot
but the thing i want more than anything
in the whole world is a new
i know none of these people but this is
snl now i don't know any of these people
i know any of these people and i'm
pausing also for transformative content
of course
of course we gotta do that yes bike love
chase oh what a good boy let's get him
that bike
and a helmet
good thinking santa who's okay honestly
let's play a game who's that
uh that is um
[__] no i know i know this guy is but
it's gonna bother me now because i can't
think of his name but i
shane gillis
with shingles right there i know that
face from something
with seth gilligan um oh and here's one
from emily
dear santa this year i want a disney
princess mirror
who's that guy what's his name
i don't know no i'm i'm i know you're
just pointing something i'm saying i
don't i don't remember the remember
the will ferrell like era of snl
you go oh that's that's this person
that's that person that's this that's
tim meadows like you
you would know everybody who they were
and it would just [__] firing off
cylinders i don't know who any of these
people are and i like by the way
i love snl like i read that [__]
giant book that's like the size of a
house
about it the unauthorized biography um
i i i always enjoyed [__] i even know
about all the [__] obscure snl people
but this is like i don't know
any of these people that's exactly
who's is is that uh what's his face um
arrested development guy
that that's what that is playing jason
bateman that that's jason because he was
on this weekend yeah
and he's and not even he can save this
[__] show
he's an actor that i i know what
you just see what she'll get huh who's
next
rupert um
rupert what is it it's just
mine's a little weird i'm sure it's not
that you're gonna really like this
you're gonna laugh really hard i think
um
okay well it starts normal enough
dear santa
no no what's the problem
you you don't get the bit so somebody's
writing santa a letter right
i want to point out that ryan long
goes out in central park stoned with a
[__] hockey stick and a mic
he doesn't do drugs and a regular camera
or whatever fine
and he he does better comedy with a mic
take to a hockey stick
than any of these [__] do with their
production budget
with the [__] rockefeller center
studio with
all like do you understand how [__]
embarrassing that is
to make such bad [__] when you have
everything at your disposal you know
what i mean like it's it's like
you got guys out there in shitty little
studios
on four track mixers making banger
albums and then you got these guys that
have like a 250 000
studio and they can't make a single song
that's what snl has become it's
you have everything here and then you
also have like
the apparatus of the media on your side
so whenever you want to push something
all the blogs will be like wow you know
is pete davidson
like you have all of that and you suck
when did this song come out by the way
that's the other thing i want to point
out when does stan come out
early 2000s right 20 years ago probably
20 years i think you might be right it
was just might have been before 9 11. it
was
some shady lp was like 99 2000. but no
no i'm sorry um marshall
this is the marshall math or something
marshall mathers lp was 99 2000 yeah
slim shady up he was like 96 97
97 or eight yeah yeah yeah
dear santa i can't believe the year is
almost over it's getting colder i'm a
year older but i'm still your soldier
you're my hero because you're always
bringing well it's because your dad's
dead so
you how did he die what happens is when
you when you lose somebody
like your father it's a very important
figure you start to replace them
with other things like santa or drugs or
drugs
don't forget drugs drugs are the way to
go but the problem is is
pete's one of these does drugs and he's
like i'm still sad
i'm sad even on drugs so once again
we're back to zero here we go my
christmas list
i won't be greedy or needy or ask you
for too much just want one thing
and hope you still got that magic touch
cause getting this present is the only
thing
it's but it's not even funny this
wouldn't have been funny
if it was done by a better snl actor
when the song came out because this
bit's not even timely right
like this bit is one that could have
been done when the song was relevant
and they would have gotten see who who
was on snl in 2000
the ferals and all that was stolen right
but i mean who would have like
pharaoh wouldn't have played this this
character would have been like uh
one of the other dudes who was another
one huh
chris parnell would have played chris
parnell yeah
would have played this shoot slim i've
called you
no you know who would have done it uh
the other night at the roxbury guy
chris katan chris kittan this tell me
this isn't it
2000 chris katan bit but it's but the
lyrics would have been funnier